Hayama: I haven't seen you for a while, but I wonder if this is what happened I have a lot
of questions I want to ask you
What happened to the store
?
It goes without saying that this is the idea of ​​General Azami, is
n't it? Wasn't it icing with you? I'd rather ask Yukihira about Shiomi cicada
.
You're probably going to rebel against the Aza San administration You're so low-minded You turned your
fangs on me with Noether Senbatsu You were trying to take the top of October Did you lie?
But it seems like my duty is to completely beat you up before I go
any higher.  If you feel like it
,
do what you want But what about the theme and the rules?
Yo,
this facility is under the jurisdiction of October
Resort.And I think there is a mechanism to mediate the winter resort's general firefighting
.
My wife who is too big will eventually get her nails done too
I hope you can get along well with that talent
So let's start explaining the
rules  The theme of the confrontation was bear meat.